這裡是AI101,
全網最幽默的AI新聞,
AI月費吃到飽的時代正在結束,
ChatGPT加入廣告200美元的方案也準備凱亮,
就連堅持不放廣告的Cloud,
訂閱補貼也可能撐不久,
這張月票的價格,
其實三年沒有動過,
2023年,
ChatGPT Plus每月20美元,
Cloud Pro也同價,
月費沒有漲,
但能用多少算力,
會變,
最先變的是免費版。
ChatGPT2月開始測試廣告
才半年8月底
OpenAI就宣稱廣告年化營收速度衝到10億美元
到了10月
OpenAI宣佈預計在月底先於美國小規模測試生圖旁的廣告
那不想看廣告的人呢
廣告只出現在Free和Go方案
免費使用者可以改選無廣告模式
代價是訊息額度更少
Plus Pro Business
Enterprise和Ideo
目前沒有廣告
免費版不看廣告
就只能接受更少功能
付費的人也沒有逃過
OpenAI每月200美元的Pro200
價格不變
但10月30日起
GPT-6 Pro每週訊息
從200則砍到100則
同樣的錢用量只剩一半
所以想用的跟以前一樣多
就得往上爬到
每月500美元的Pro500
可是獨立研究機構
Semi Analysis估算
它的量只比舊的200美元方案
多約21%
奇怪的是
開發者用的API反而在降價
API是讓城市照用量呼叫模型
用多少付多少的界面
GPT-6 SOAR和LUNA的價格大約減半
OPUS 5.5的表價也降了20%
為什麼月票反而縮水
Semi Analysis估算
同樣每月20美元
Cloud Pro能用約29億Tokens
ChatGPT Plus只有約10億
差了大約2.9倍
給的這麼大方
代價不小
Semi Analysis
錯估Cloud訂閱吃掉Anthropic
約41.7%的推論算力
卻只帶來約10%的營收
這張月票可能是一筆昂貴的補貼
那Anthropic也放廣告呢?
他早就承諾不會還在抄幾杯廣告直說
廣告會來到AI,但不會來Cloud
所以,若要降低訂閱補貼
能調的旋鈕就更集中在價格、額度和模型權限
偏偏Anthropic的財務壓力很大
招股書顯示,2025年營收約46億美元
營業損失卻有約80.6億美元
營業損失比營收還大
往後看,10月還有三個日子
會讓免費和付費都更緊
10月9日起
Gemini免費版預定只剩Flashlight
10月29日
Pro 200就額度到期
10月底
ChatGPT預計在美國小規模測試深圖旁的廣告
把這些拼起來
AI公司正在收回
讓使用者靠固定月票大量消耗算力的補貼
免費使用者用注意力付
重度使用者用更高月費付
吃到飽
正變成隨時能調整額度的信用池
追蹤AI101
不錯過AI圈的最新消息